Mình sẽ không có thể làm giá tăng áp lực lên của anh dự chứ đạn dược của Mỹ.
Theo bằng cao có là vụ khi có thể bị điều chuyển bao gồm tên lượng đến trận không không,
vốn được mua thông qua sản kế của nato.
Theo đỏ các nước đối tác tài chờ để mua vụ khi Mỹ cho khi em.
Lần tháng này, dễn ra khi mà đồng con sử của Mỹ tại chủ đồng gia tăng,
tư lạnh một chỉ vì chủ tâm Mỹ đồ đó của các bạn của cho biết,
lượng Mỹ đã tấn công hơn một người nghiệm một tiêu bên trọng Iran và đang hướng tới việc hạn trên ở lực trình
khá xương mạnh của Tehran, Zabin Waix.
Một người phát ngôn lượng đồng có khẳng định,
một chi trình Mỹ sẽ đảm bảo các lượng Mỹ của đồng mình có đủ nợ lực cần thiết để tắc chuyển hiệu qua.
Trong khi đó, một qua trước nà tổ cho biết, các nước thành viên và đối tác vẫn tiếp tục đồng góch cho chương trình cùng các tụi châu quay nà.
Nhưng mành giòn viện cho con sử chủ kia và đà được vui gì với tổng trả trị lên tới hạn tì đô.